hey what's up I'm Jesse welcome back to
the Wolfram tech conference 2018 like
technology in really interesting ways
right now I'm here with Carlo so can you
tell me like what you do here at Wolfram
and like what your focus is on oh that's
a hard question really because that
Wolfram is like a really interesting
company and I over the years I got to
work on completely different things
my latest focus is on integrating
relational databases with language and
it's been a really challenging project
one of the longest I've worked on it's
not done yet but we're excited because
it's like really the first time that
we're bringing out of core data science
from language it was very important
missing piece and I'm proud to be
involved it cool well can you tell me a
little bit about what you've been doing
no we've had database link so you say we
had database link sort of in language I
think that that sort of is very
important database link is like an
external package and as such we feel in
general that things that stay out of the
system context have not been really
blessed and so it's like they lack the
level of polish that we expect for from
the things that are in the main language
and so I mean their base link is a fine
piece of technology but in terms of in
end user interface the arguments of the
function and so on it still feels a
little bit different from the rest of my
of the Wolfram language and as such now
we are trying to get a more modern
approach to talking to the database
there are still some things that
database link does more than we do right
now for example database link has
capabilities to write to this base which
we don't yet but the business is more
low-level you often end up having to
write raw SQL and and that's somewhat
unfortunate I mean why wouldn't you
write it directly at that point language
okay so it is a feature of many
programming languages especially
object-oriented programming languages to
have something that is called the ORM or
object relational mapping obviously we
cannot have an object relational mapping
in a language that is not object
oriented and so at some point there was
a moment of a realization that was
happened at the same time from
my team side and from the part of
Wolfram research that's working on the
knowledge base in alpha that the way we
represent knowledge in alpha could blend
well with with a some sort of symbolic
quorum and so the idea is that you have
something that represents a query in SQL
and it's fully symbolic just like many
things in Mathematica it uses a
functional style nesting but it stays
fully symbolic so you can manipulate it
in many ways
you can you can use advanced advanced
programming techniques like meta
programming to generate the query and
then it gets executed in in one go in
one simple block so the design is rather
simple and rather elegant of course
there are a lot of challenges in making
that actually work because the SQL work
is I would say is through many different
situations out there so yeah I guess the
the main problem is that there are many
dialect of SQL and within each dialogue
are several versions several levels of
support different syntaxes and and
syntaxes that are in general not only
different among SQL dialects but very
different with with respect to the
semantics of the Wolfram language and so
like the Wolfram language is very
loosely typed SQL is very strongly typed
though not all of SQL dialects are
strong typed and so like to have
something that feels natural when you're
used to writing off your language code
is actually pretty hard
so and you would say that you were able
to sort of blend this with SQL rather
well for the user to feel like they're
comfortable enough writing database
queries yeah I think I think right now
it it feels very natural people don't
really have to worry too much about the
ins and out of whether you know SQL has
this very weird historical features like
that drive from the fact that it was
used starting in the 70s by banking
corporations and so for example to give
an example there's a way of storing
numbers that is I think still exists all
in SQL that is called decimal or numeric
so instead of the numbers being stored
as floating-point in binary they're
stored directly in decimal form just
like when you write them down and that's
because you absolutely don't want
rounding errors when you're dealing with
money and so when you have dollars and
cents they have to be exact
dollars in a sense and that's something
that most modern programming languages
don't support anymore but it still
exists in SQL should our users worry
about that or not fortunately the
Wolfram language has extremely good
precision tracking so it's not a problem
but in you know there's a lot of
engineering that goes into making these
two things talk together so I guess we
talked a lot about
implementation to get this to work what
are some common workflows that you see a
user using this sort of so first of all
you need to connect to so there is a
there is a symbolic representation of
the connection of the so user
name/password what the host in the port
is once you connect the first step is
inspecting the database view of what's
in there then once you're inspected the
database you only have information
that's very raw SQL and we lift that
into an entity store that can be then
registered and queried now once you have
the data in an entity store I mean the
data is not really in there it's still
in the database and it might be much
much larger than the memory with a
computer there are databases out there
with terabytes of data coming from
everything from logs of websites to
scientific data especially in biology
they have now huge droves of gene
expression and genomes and proteins and
so on so once you have the data
connected through an entity store you
can perform queries that generally will
make the data viable for usage within
your machine
so obviously Mathematica has thousands
and thousands of functions ranging from
mathematics to geo where computations
and so on and most SQL databases don't
support that stuff and so in general
what you want to do is like kind of
aggregate the data or digest it in a way
that it then it is small enough that you
can then manipulate
with with the Wolfram language and so it
allows for some kind of hybrid workflow
where you deal with the really really
large stuff out of core completely and
you bring it in and then you can use all
sorts of visualization or I don't know
you can you want to do some data
rithmetic or maps and whatnot you can
integrate it with our own knowledge base
so for example if you have some data
that is Geographic in nature then you
can absolutely link it with things that
we know about those regions like the
population so it's it's really I think
it's it's really nice how it all blends
together because you can have a fully
hybrid workflow but it doesn't feel like
you're using five different products or
five different programming languages as
it would be if you were doing this in
the next few years where do you see this
I think that the first next step the
mean next step is to be able to write to
databases so it's been we've had over
the years several products that aim to
let people for example log visits to a
website so if you I in the past I have
worked on things like form function and
API function and it's often a request of
our users like to be able to say I want
to do a survey there are many people
coming to my website the enter data and
they write it down
databases are exceptional for this kind
of thing because they're designed for
concurrency and to preserve atomicity of
the transactions and so I think it will
be very important as we expand also our
capabilities on the cloud to let people
write to the database if you think about
something like a website like I don't
know Airbnb
or Facebook to us developers a website
like that is really a giant database
with little skin around this probably
somebody who does front-end development
would feel insulted by this but it is
true that if you think about it like
when you go to Airbnb
like and you scroll around map then they
are like doing some geofencing to figure
out what apartments to show you that are
in the map in that moment all that stuff
is torn in database and then there are
tables for users tables for trips for
financial transactions should break
something your apartment they have to
know you know who to give the money to
and so on so it's it's it's really very
important for more than what happened to
be able to write do you have any other
comments you want to well I think that I
mean maybe I should have just want to
say it but I think that what we're doing
is really in a sense groundbreaking
because I mean there's a long history of
integrating databases with object
oriented languages but I've never seen
something that I mean the Wolfram
language is very unique language in the
fact that you can really manipulate
everything code and data are the same
thing there are languages that are like
that but they usually are not as easy to
use at least because that comes to mind
and so I guess that this is a new form
of relational mapping I wouldn't call it
object relational mapping maybe it's
like a symbolic relational mapping
and there is not much out there that
looks like it so I'm really excited I
think there are a lot of new ideas yeah
thanks for taking the time to hang out
with me and talk thank you
[Music]